Conozco a un hombre que vuela sobre la ciudad todas las noches.
En sus sueños, gira y gira
con sus pies besando el suelo.
"Todo se mueve", dice,
incluso su propio cuerpo paralizado.
Este hombre es mi padre.
Hace tres años, cuando me enteré
de que mi padre había sufrido un grave derrame cerebral,
en el tronco encefálico,
entré en su habitación, en la UCI
del Instituto Neurológico de Montreal
y lo encontré tumbado, casi muerto,
unido a una máquina para respirar.
La parálisis había apagado su cuerpo lentamente
empezando por los talones, después las piernas,
el torso, los dedos y los brazos.
hasta llegar al cuello,
quitándole la capacidad de respirar,
y se detuvo justo debajo de sus ojos.
Nunca perdió la conciencia.
Todo lo contrario, desde su interior vio
cómo se paralizaba su cuerpo,
miembro a miembro,
músculo a músculo,
En aquella habitación de la UCI, me aproximé a su cuerpo,
y en medio de las lágrimas con voz temblorosa,
empecé a recitar el alfabeto
A, B, C, D, E, F, G,
H, I, J, K.
En la K, sus ojos pestañearon.
Comencé otra vez,
A, B, C, D, E, F, G,
H, I,
Volvió a pestañear en la I,
luego en la T, luego en la R, y en la A
Kitra.
Dijo: "Kitra, mi linda, no llores.
Esto es una bendición".
No era una voz audible, pero mi padre
había dicho mi nombre de forma rotunda.
Tan solo 24 horas después del derrame cerebral,
había asumido ya
plenamente su condición.
A pesar de la gravedad de su estado,
estaba totalmente presente conmigo,
guiándome, nutriéndome
e incluso siendo mi padre
mucho más que antes.
El síndrome de enclaustramiento
es para mucha gente la peor de las pesadillas.
En francés, se llama a veces
"maladie de l'emmuré vivant".
Literalmente, "enfermedad del empaderamiento vivo".
Puede que para la mayoría de la gente
la parálisis sea un horror indescriptible,
pero la experiencia de mi padre
al perder todos las funciones de su cuerpo
no fue la de sentirse atrapado,
sino más bien de interiorización,
atenuando el bullicio externo,
y enfrentándose a los recovecos de su mente
para en ese lugar,
volver a enamorarse de la vida y de su cuerpo.
Como rabino y hombre espiritual.
suspendido entre el cuerpo y la mente, la vida y la muerte,
la parálisis le despertó a una nueva conciencia.
Se dio cuenta de que ya no necesitaba mirar
más allá del mundo corporal
para encontrar la divinidad.
"El paraíso está en este cuerpo
en este mundo", decía.
Dormí al lado de mi padre durante los primeros 4 meses
cuidándole todo lo que pude,
en su malestar,
entendiendo el profundo miedo psicológico humano
de no poder pedir ayuda.
Mi madre, hermanas, hermanos y yo
le rodeamos como en un capullo de curación.
Nos convertimos en su boca,
recitando durante horas el abecedario cada día,
mientras él susurraba sermones
y poesía con el pestañeo de sus ojos.
Su habitación se transformó en un templo de curación.
Los pies de su cama un lugar para quienes
buscaban aviso y consejo espiritual, y a través de nosotros,
mi padre fue capaz de hablar.
y de recuperarse,
letra a letra,
pestañeo a pestañeo.
Todo en nuestro mundo se volvió lento y tierno,
mientras el estruendo, el drama y la muerte de la sala del hospital
se desvanecían en el trasfondo.
Quiero leer una de las primeras cosas
que transcribimos después de la primera semana del derrame cerebral.
Compuso una carta,
dirigida a la congregación de su sinagoga
que terminaba con las siguientes líneas:
"Cuando mi cabeza explotó,
entré en otra dimensión:
incipiente, subplanetaria, protozoaria.
Los universos se abren y cierran continuamente
Hay mucha gente que cuando está mal
deja de crecer.
La semana anterior estaba muy mal,
pero sentí la mano de mi padre alrededor,
y mi padre me trajo de vuelta".
Cuando no éramos su voz,
éramos sus piernas y sus brazos.
Se los movía como me hubiera gustado
que se movieran mis piernas y brazos
si hubieran estado paralizados todo el día.
Recuerdo que sostenía sus dedos cerca de mi rostro,
doblando cada articulación para mantenerlas suaves y sensibles.
Le pedía una y otra vez
que visualizara el movimiento,
que mirase por dentro cómo los dedos se curvaban,
se extendían y se movían conmigo
en su mente.
Entonces, un día, por el rabillo del ojo
vi su cuerpo deslizarse como una serpiente,
una espasmo involuntario que atravesaba
todos sus miembros.
Al principio, creí que era una alucinación,
por estar tanto tiempo tumbada junto a su cuerpo,
desesperada por ver cualquier tipo de reacción.
Pero me dijo que sentía un hormigueo,
chispas de electricidad que se encendían y se apagaban,
justo debajo de la piel.
A la semana siguiente, incluso empezó a mostrar ligeramente
cierta resistencia muscular.
Se habían hecho conexiones.
El cuerpo despertaba, lenta y suavemente,
miembro a miembro, músculo a músculo,
contracción a contradicción.
Como un reportera gráfica
sentía la necesidad de fotografiar
cada uno de sus primeros movimientos,
como una madre con su recién nacido.
Fotografié su primera respiración no asistida,
el momento posterior de celebración,
la resistencia de sus músculos por primera vez.
Las nuevas tecnologías adaptadas le permitieron
ganar más y más independencia.
Fotografié el cuidado y el amor
que lo rodeaban.
Pero mis fotografías solo cuentan la historia externa
de un hombre tumbado en la cama de un hospital
unido a una máquina de respirar.
No fui capaz de retratar su historia contada desde dentro,
y por eso, empecé a buscar un nuevo lenguaje visual.
con el que pudiera expresar la cualidad efímera
de su experiencia espiritual.
Finalmente, quiero compartirles
un video de una de las series en las que estoy trabajando,
que trata de expresar la lentitud entre ambas existencias
que mi padre ha experimentado.
Cuando comenzó a recuperar su capacidad para respirar
empecé a grabar sus pensamientos,
y la voz que escuchan en el video
es su voz.
(Ronnie Cahana): Tienes que creer
que estás paralizado,
actuar el papel
de un cuadripléjico.
Yo no.
En mi mente
y en mis sueños
cada noche,
soy uno de esos hombres de Chagall que vuelan
sobre la ciudad,
girando y girando
con mis pies besando el suelo.
No sé nada sobre la afirmación
de un hombre sin movimiento.
Todo se mueve.
El corazón late.
El cuerpo nos tira.
La boca se mueve.
Nunca nos estancamos.
La vida triunfa con sus altos y bajos.
(Kitra Cahana): Para la mayoría,
los músculos empiezan a girar y moverse
mucho antes de que somos conscientes,
pero mi padre me dice que es un privilegio
vivir en la periferia lejana
de la experiencia humana.
Como un astronauta que ve una perspectiva
que muy pocos de nosotros llegaremos a compartir;
él se maravilla y mira mientras
respira por primera vez,
y sueña volver gateando a casa.
Por eso dice que su vida comenzó a los 57 años.
Un niño no tiene actitud en su ser,
pero un hombre insiste en su mundo cada día.
Solo unos pocos tendrán que hacer frente a las limitaciones físicas
hasta el extremo en que lo hizo mi padre,
pero todos tendremos momentos de parálisis
en la vida.
Sé que me enfrento a muros que con frecuencia,
me parecen imposibles de escalar,
pero mi padre insiste
en que no hay callejones sin salida.
Y, por el contrario, me invita a su espacio de co-curación
para que dé lo mejor de mí misma,
y él darme lo mejor de sí mismo.
La parálisis fue un comienzo para él.
Una oportunidad para emerger,
reavivar la fuerza vital,
sentarse con tranquilidad consigo mismo,
para enamorarse con el flujo continuo
de la creación.
Hoy, mi padre ya no está atrapado.
Mueve el cuello con facilidad,
le han quitado el alimentador,
respira con sus propios pulmones,
habla despacio y con voz tranquila,
y trabaja cada día
para conseguir más movimiento en su cuerpo paralizado.
Pero el trabajo nunca terminará.
Como dice: "Vivo en un mundo destrozado
donde hay un trabajo sagrado que hacer".
Gracias
(Aplausos).